well a former Florida police officer
faces life in prison for killing a black
man who stranded on the side of the road
41 year old Nouman Raja was found guilty
of manslaughter and attempted murder a
jury convicted him of killing 31 year
old Corey Jones in 2015 Erol Burnett is
in West Palm Beach
Erol good morning good morning this is
the first conviction of a Florida police
officer involved in an on-duty shooting
in some three decades and it took the
all-white jury here just four hours to
return its verdict and to bring some
sort of relief for the Jones family song
we did it for more than three years
Corey Jones family agonized over his
death by former police officer Nouman
Raja
after verdict we went straight to the
gravesite it was just like below lifted
resolution came in court Thursday
Raja showed no emotion as the guilty
verdicts were read he was on duty in
plain clothes and an unmarked van when
he killed Jones in October of 2015
Jones was waiting for a tow truck after
his SUV broke down the truth will
prevail over lies every time Raja told
investigators he identified himself as
an officer but an audio recording of
Jones call with roadside assistance
proved he never did Benjamin Crump is
the Jones family attorney and had it not
been for that recording he would have
got away with murder the defense argued
that Raja fired out of fear for his life
when Jones pulled out a gun but
prosecutors said Jones who had a
concealed carry permit for his firearm
thought he was getting robbed since 2005
98 officers have been arrested for
murder or manslaughter while on duty
only 10 of them have been convicted of
manslaughter that we got a guilty
verdict it gives us a hope
there things can change the Jones family
tells me they now plan to file a
wrongful death civil suit with the
criminal trial over Raja has a
sentencing hearing scheduled for next
month where he faces a mandatory minimum
sentence of 25 years behind bars
Norah all right Errol thank you